the author of out of the pocket football
fatherhood and college game day
saturdays he is uh that's available
where all books are sold he is kirk herb
street back here on the rich eisen show
how you doing kirk
i'm good bud how you doing i'm better
for talking to you how you been life's
good good family
at the hall of fame i enjoyed uh
i know we missed out on last year but i
thought it was it was really well done
how they they put it on back-to-back
nights and
every every time i watch every speech
and and it just uh
you kind of leave inspired you know i
thought they all kind of hit different
areas of uh
the messaging but uh loved them all i
thought peyton hit a home run with uh i
thought he was about to go strictly snl
peyton on us there for a second but then
you ended up with
a great message a lot of fun i'll tell
you what what was most impressive about
peyton manning's it wasn't a speech
it was a presentation uh you know i've
been fortunate to see he hear and
witness all manners of hall of fame
speeches
and his
speech
had a photograph to go with each line
and every single time he mentioned
somebody or something the photograph to
use the television phrase i'm sure
you're familiar with hot changed to the
next one and whoever was in charge of
that button
for the pro football hall of fame had
the most pressure on him or her
to make sure that peyton manning got off
the stage
knowing that his presentation as it
intended
landed and it was spectacular the
message and then the in what the way he
delivered it too was just let me tell
you i've done i've done a speech with
him where he and i kind of kind of uh
did it together and i
he asked there was a deal in nashville
and it was it was about pat's summit it
was honoring pat summitt and
he um
he texted me
like 50 questions
and then he voice texted me like the
next day
another eight minutes of okay forget
number two you know
and then number six now don't worry
about that six we've already covered up
and he goes through eight minutes voice
text eight minutes
and then by the time we're gonna i
usually you do those there's there's no
stress you know you're sitting there
with peyton we just we'll just wing it
you know we'll go for 40 35 whatever
we're gonna do and
he had me so wigged out on
on like like skip number two do i go to
number three i mean it was
but he and then he's like kirk it's
funny you asked that question you know
he just did incredible with his
presentation
i love that he's he's truly one of the
most prepared individuals yes that
you've ever met and the most
professional individuals you've ever met
and somebody who's so prepared and wants
to make sure everything goes the way
that he wants
the fact that he is also potentially
the most well known for audibling and
omaha at the line of scrimmage it truly
is remarkable
how you put it all together you know
yeah the the snl stuff that he does
yeah just legendary legendary the fake
united way commercial where he's winging
it at children is one of the greatest
sketches of all time they're beeping him
out
what are you doing no question about it
and it's kind of interesting and just to
i guess uh
put a point on this part of our
discussion that he goes in the hall of
fame with charles woodson and that was
you know the two guys uh who went
finished uh one two for the heisman in
97. you know and and we showed a
photograph of who else was in new york
that day randy moss was in new york i
mean oh my goodness gracious what a
class that was back in in 97 you know uh
kirk hurstv here on the rich eisen show
uh before we get into your book uh i i
believe you tell me if i'm way off here
we're beginning to see the beginning of
a super league in college football that
works that way you know i think we're
seeing it one league or you think it's
four leagues here's the way i'm seeing
it people think it's four leagues i
think i don't know how we're going to
get there
but you know
everybody
watching oklahoma and texas do what they
did
uh everybody else in every other
conference is going to have to band
together to make sure nobody else peels
off to join them
and they're going to have to band
together and at some point when you got
maybe two or three or four super leagues
it'll just make sense to do the whole
damn thing you know yeah and
i think that's inevitable
kirk right now
i think we're all we're all left to
speculate right now because we're we're
kind of in a tsunami with with college
football you know it's just
the sec has been a behemoth and now they
bring in the two brands of oh you in
texas and it's like where did that come
we're just we're just trying to get our
arms around name image and likeness and
transfer portal and now we got
texas you know you went in the sec
um man what happened there and
you're left with the big 12 with some
still some really good brands you know
like oklahoma state and
um
tcu west virginia iowa state is a top 10
team right now the job matt campbell's
doing
so i don't know
part of me is excited about what the sec
has going but the other part of me is
like where where are we headed what's
happening what's good what's the big ten
gonna do what what's the pac-12 going to
do what's left of the big 12 and so
i i feel the same way that my biggest
concern with this whole thing is
we don't have a roger goodell in college
football we have five we have f well i
know i'm just saying we don't have a
commissioner we don't have a one voice
whether you like him or you don't you
don't like his statement what he's going
to do or his ruling here's the here's
the voice roger goodell boom there's the
ruling
here we have greg sankey he's looking
after his constituents right his players
his coaches his ads his presidents his
fans he doesn't care what's going on on
the west coast west coast didn't care
what's going on in the big ten big ten
gun care about the big 12 or the sec so
they're all worried about their own
world well how are we collectively
as a sport gonna move the ball down the
field when we got five different agendas
working in different places you know
that's so i think the i think the the
the covid year
taught us a lot of things but one of the
things that taught us about college
football is we need one voice it's okay
to have four or five voices that report
to the one voice but that one voice
needs to make some decisions
that will collectively help the sport
move down as i say move the ball down
the field to help the greater good of
college football not just the greater
good of the sec by the greater good of
the big ten we we need to move uh and
that's why i think i would be i i
wouldn't be surprised to see them pull
away from the ncaa
create their own governing body
find a commissioner and just and just
start doing it that way no doubt about
it because i mean kirk herb street here
again his book out of pocket football
fatherhood college game day saturday is
available or all books are sold we'll
talk about that in a second
no question about it i mean you
mentioned the coveteer
covert as we know has ravaged ravaged
budgets across college sports and
athletics and
for
ends to continue to be met
certainly with title ix requirements as
well you got to look for money and
everybody is going to make this sort of
decision oklahoma texas gold rush is
going to be on here and i'm
i'm my eyes are peeled right now kirk
and again you tell me if i'm i'm off or
you think you know this is this is
something that i'm on you know that i
don't know if i'm reinventing the
wheeler but my eyes on clemson and ohio
state and
the athletic directors there and the
school presidents there if ohio state
decided to say you know what we're going
to join the sec right now and clemson
did the same thing right now
poof
honestly and and it would be
remarkable if michigan and ohio state
didn't you know converse on this subject
together if if michigan does decide to
do something like this like that's where
this thing kind of goes as far as i'm
concerned because wow you mean i've
never even
never really thought about everybody
just kind of going into as you're saying
one big league i've kind of looked at it
as i see us having potentially for these
super
conferences and and they they kind of
go away and leave and and just like i
said create their own world but uh
i i never until you said that i never
really heard heard that perspective or
that idea maybe i could be i'm holding
on to hope that there's something really
fun about college football that you know
the the midwest you know the big ten
region and the sec and pac-12 and
everybody kind of pride themselves on
on on being strong you know it's just
like the nfl like you know different
divisions like to think that they play
the best
version of football and there's some
pride within the nfc afc and i think
with college football the roots go even
deeper and and take away
that you know we're taking away
tradition we're taking away rivalries
you know and that that to me is
it's a little bit of a slippery slope um
but
you know i'm trying my best to to as a
traditionalist i'm trying my best to
keep an open mind to all these things
that are happening but it's it's a
little bit scary well i respect that
from you kirk because you know in a
super league
i know it'll be you and fowler calling
the biggest games
you know
these pieces of filet mignon will be
placed on your plate to serve to the
rest of america you know so i respect
your approach on that you know um
because honestly i just think that
this is the the way it's all going to go
and how would you say the nil first
blush has hit and coaches that you've
spoken to are they open to it do they
view this as potentially you know locker
room splitting that somebody's going to
make a million and other kids who are
you know 90 to 120 that make up special
teams on things like that
uh aren't privy to it like what do you
think i think they're concerned i think
time will tell i i i would not be
surprised to see
some of these companies are doing a an
entire roster where everybody gets a
thousand bucks or everybody gets you
know whatever it might be
and then at least everybody gets
something and then you know if you have
a quarterback or you have whoever the
star the player start playing your team
is gets you know some of these these
crazy deals that that maybe is a little
bit easier to accept first people having
nothing um you know so i i think it's a
little bit of a wait and see approach
there is a little bit of people
overreacting to it i was just on an espn
call on a seminar and they said i think
there'd been over 1300 deals 53 percent
of which are outside of college football
and outside of men's basketball which i
found interesting and the average deal
is 923
so i don't know if it's is you know the
sky is falling all these kids are going
to be making millions of dollars the way
you know there's been a handful or a
couple guys have been reportedly making
you know good money the brice young
story of alabama when nick saban was at
a
speech in texas and he said hey you know
our quarterback hadn't taken a snap but
he's already close to seven figures um
that doesn't accidentally come out you
know from from nick saban but i i don't
know i i'm still kind of six weeks in
just kind of watching i think a lot of
this stuff is social media driven
tick tock and instagram and twitter and
things like that based on how many
followers you have what will dictate you
know how much money you get paid per
tweet so it's not like you're going down
to bubba's to go get a new car every
every week and things the way it's being
portrayed at least at this point it
hasn't been that way after six weeks
before we get to your book kirk
kerbstreet um i do want to ask you about
justin fields because that was a large
part of our conversation last we spoke
prior i think it was either just before
or after the draft that you obviously
helped broadcast for the worldwide
leader and now we just saw what he did
albeit against the twos i get it uh in
his first preseason game i i cannot
think that we see that anything
twitching in that direction but by him
against the bills that that matt neggie
would start to have to think based on
what i'm assuming is happening
blossoming inside the walls of that
building meeting rooms and such
going in fields direction to start the
season what do you think of what we saw
from fields this weekend well first i'll
just go back to our conversation if you
remember i i was i wasn't this way with
dwayne haskins because you know it's not
like oh it's a buckeye quarterback so
he's going to go to bat form but i was
this way with justin fields and it's
because of what's inside his chest
this kid is
as competitive as a guy as you're ever
going to meet and when you throw on top
of that the skill set
and he you know he somehow creates an
edge like the world's against him he
even did it at ohio state and i
sometimes i was like bro like you've
been on top of the mountain your whole
life i mean i appreciate you got a chip
on your shoulder i don't know where it
comes from but everyone loves you uh but
then leading into the draft they didn't
you know he took he was the one
quarterback who took a lot of hits
and
he man i've never seen a guy
with more of an eye of the tiger like
i'm going to show them
that that that was genuine than justin
fields you know leading into the draft
and he gets drafted and i've told people
in chicago's like congratulations
because you finally got your franchise
quarterback
and i don't know i'm not going by what
he did the other day i'm with you it's
first game they're not showing a lot of
coverage
it's it's exhibition football the game
changes dramatically you know better
than anybody from exhibition football to
real football but
there's just a lot there to like and a
lot of what was being said about him
last one there first one to leave and
all that kind of nonsense was really the
furthest thing from the truth
his teammates love him hard worker
and you know like i said i until you see
him in person you don't realize how big
and imposing he is and that's how
athletic he is as far as his ability to
create and he's got a big arm so there
if he picks up the offense
um i i'm excited to watch the bears and
i'm excited to see them grow around him
once he eventually gets his chance
whether they give andy the nod early or
eventually at some point obviously
they're gonna hand the reins over to
justin fields but he's got a huge future
in my mind well and also a mac jones
looks to be
having he looks the part right and in
this offense knowing how to to maneuver
it the way josh mcdaniels wants and
protect it the way that belichick wants
and then in terms of a fit i cannot
imagine belichick serving anything up
coaching style tough love style that mac
jones hasn't already absorbed from nick
saban right right i mean like that and i
think there's a reason that that that
coach belichick continues to look
closely in tuscaloosa for players that
might be able to help him out just
because it's it's kind of turnkey you
know as far as the culture they go from
one to the next it's it's just an
extension of what they learned while
they were at alabama with coach saban
of all the quarterbacks to me he he
processes things the quickest and and i
think coming out of sarc's offense which
is probably the most nfl friendly
that that was the one thing on mac jones
if you're going to look at him in a pair
of shorts and go to the combine and
compare him to some of these other guys
you're probably going to say he's
accurate but when you throw him up on a
board or you watch him talk about film
and watch how quickly his brain sees
things and how quickly he communicates
that which is right up bill belichick
and josh mcdaniels right up there alley
it would be it would shock me if he
doesn't go there and have a really
really good opportunity to have some
success there i think that's a perfect
fit for him i don't know if you could
hand pick the better fit uh for him than
to go to to new england and be in that
offense out of the pocket football
fatherhood and college game day
saturdays kirk kerb street
congratulations on the book why and uh
and
what
are they i guess the two questions about
you with this book
you know it's it's not it's not just
football or my broadcast uh journey that
i've been on it's
you know it's a little bit deeper than
that we gene wojciechowski who's a
friend of mine and you know him well he
works at espn on game day and a great
author has written several books he
approached me and just wanted to just
kind of tell my story he knows me well
enough to know
about um you know my background i came
from a kind of a dysfunctional family
and
um
parents divorced when i was eight it it
took a effect on on me quite a bit my
dad was my hero you know i played at
ohio state he was a captain and
i grew up loving ohio state and he was a
big part of that and then at eight years
old he was
he was gone and um kind of out of my
life for a while and remarried a woman
and
and um kind of immersed himself into
that family and he was in and out and um
and you know i didn't have you know some
kids go through divorce they have
resentment
they have anger and hostility turned to
drugs sometimes for me it was more of an
kind of an emptiness
just didn't really have the relationship
that i wanted and that continued
throughout most of my life um even when
i had kids myself it was just kind of a
strange deal so it just gene talked me
into becoming
i guess vulnerable for a guy that's
incredibly introverted and shy and not
comfortable in talking about
how i feel about things this this is one
way to kind of get things i guess off
your chest is to write a book about it
so there's a lot there about being a son
and then eventually becoming a father
and
by no means my acting like i have all
the answers if anything it's the
opposite i'm just kind of telling you
about how i'm trying to learn as i go
here and
you know i ask my boys all the time
because i didn't have a dad at home i
always ask him if i'm doing an okay job
you know because
you know you you get into some big
decisions as a dad and you just do the
best you can and
um i guess more than anything it's a
book that i hope resonates with some
folks and maybe been through
some similar things and and um i don't
know i just i just thought it with gene
it felt comfortable and
and opening up so that's that's not the
whole book but that's
a big portion of it and then we get into
just my journey which was kind of an
anomaly as just a pretty solid big ten
quarterback i wasn't like dez didn't win
heisman didn't win all you know one
all-american
go to super bowls and yet
um how i got to the position that i'm in
uh on abc with chris calling the biggest
games of the week and calling national
championships and been on game day for
26 years 26 how in the world did i get
here sometimes i look i asked myself
that and so
i kind of talked about
how that came about and how uh you know
that's something i never take for
granted no data and go by that i don't
take i think about how fortunate i am to
have the position that i have in
broadcasting and especially at espn and
covering football beautifully put kirk i
mean it's nothing more personal than
writing a book and the fact that you put
so much personal stuff in there it's
something that you're gonna you're gonna
love
you know i'm sure you get a lot of
plaudits from people who come up to you
um talking about what you do and how you
do it anybody comes up to you says i
love your book that's just gonna be the
greatest thing period and the story and
i speak as somebody who whose book can
be gotten for one cent right now
probably somewhere um
don't look it up chris you can get it
for a cent
he's already saying hold on it's just
again beautiful and and and i hope that
you're sharing has uh improved things
for you
kirk yeah i mean it's still hard for me
um
it just i think it's the way you're
wired you know it's just one of those
things i was a kid you're probably
opposite of you you seem to be very
comfortable in your skin you know when
you were a kid if they asked you to get
up and give a speech i would pass like i
would just say no thanks i'll take a
zero
and uh teacher would be like um it's 25
percent of your grade your final grade
i'm like i'm good you know you can go
ahead go to the next person um so to go
from that to
you know working in in tv and on a you
know national broadcast every week is
definitely not what i expected to do
that's for sure
well i know you've been speaking a lot
about the book appreciate you stopping
by here we'd love to have you once the
games start let's talk let's do it thank
you kirk
love to absolutely good luck to your
wolves this year uh i don't think you
mean that but that's okay
no i know you mean it i i i have no idea
honestly uh anybody asks me i'm like it
just depends if jim has got the
quarterback that's it man yeah well
that's been the story that's it that's
been a story for a number of years i was
on with leroy horde earlier you know on
this
just talking to a lot of different
people and first of all i told him how
great he was i mean that's the michigan
running oh yes it is
leroy was the last time michigan had a
back
it was you know you anthony thomas ty
weekly
for sure good it was a good college back
but was the last time they had leroy
hart back there
and and the same with quarterback it was
the last great michigan quarterback i i
guess henny chad henny back in 07. sure
maybe i mean think about that so if if
michigan wants to win in the fall they
got to win in in february you got to win
in recruiting and development but
uh
i was watching last thing big 10 network
last night had the usc michigan 89 rose
bowl on gerard bunch i covered that game
that was my that was well it was the
eighteen i was nineteen it was the 89
season 1990 89 89 rose bowl okay yeah
to my last year junior usc junior sale
mark carrier rodney p i mean it was just
awesome right i watched the whole game
and i'm thinking
that's michigan right there well i
covered i did not look like that kirk i
covered bo's last game that was my my
senior year of college i was at that
rose bowl it was todd marinovich beaten
elvis gerbach desmond howard your
colleague was
had a nice catch in the game and we had
no idea what was to come from him
um in the rest of his career but i just
remember this there was a guy in usc
number 55 i literally had to look down
at the i i had to look down
at the uh at the the number sheet that i
got you know of the flip card to see if
there were two of them i literally had
two i stopped at one point i'm like i'm
like oh my god
is there are there 255's i thought about
it he was a great pro but he was a
ridiculous
college player unbelievable never seen
anything like it yeah ever yeah i
literally looked to see are there 255s
on usc and if so i believe
kirk you take care of yourself we'll
chat down the line thanks man congrats
on the book thanks man you bet all books
are sold get out of pocket out of the
pocket football fatherhood in the
college and college game day saturdays
kirk curve street at kirkherb street on
twitter and instagram what a story so
glad that he's sharing it hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here